whether you're a ceo in charge of a
thousand people whether you're a startup
whether it's just you and your best
friend story is what we use to organize
what's important in our lives
what are we doing
how are we doing it but most importantly
why it doesn't matter
a good story entices the audience to
care
a good story
creates some sense of tension some
conflict develops that conflict and
finds a way to deliver a resolution
a good story is one that you want to
repeat
the best storytelling tip i can give to
leaders is to remember that people
already want to believe in you they
already
want you to be
a strong intelligent focused leader
and that your story
is going to be proof back to them that
they were right that they should believe
in you
and so the story that you give them is
going to be one filled with the right
kind of information so that they know
what direction you're going but they
also know what they can do to help you
get there
we don't have a fundamental human need
to click a button
to download an app or to like sync your
settings
we have fundamental human needs like
healthy happy family
like creative productive fun work like
feeling that the effort that we put out
into the world
can result in meaningful consequences
positive meaningful consequences
so what makes me happy is when all of
those things can align
healthy happy
loving family
meaningful work
you